hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach I don't know if you guys remember
what happens to this particular SCP uh
it's a little interesting I'm going to
actually do it so that you guys can see
it before anything but um you think
about this particular SCP am i dead
did I die have I expired I died
well we know is that he died of cardiac
arrest my guess is oh is caused by
scp-896 EP 8 9 5 s red zone is
increasing well so that's the thing
about SCP 8 8 9 5 this particular SCP
doesn't affect people that are
physically arounded but only affects
people that are watching it through
video streams and I don't know why but
that doesn't bode well in the age of
live streams that we're currently in
right now so let's low back into this
hopefully oh good it loads so quickly so
you can actually turn this off which is
smart because then you're not looking at
it and you're not going to die and
previously I believe the last time then
I played this which is a long time ago I
mistakenly identified that as a radical
Larry's place of origin which I don't
want to be it right now so we're in a
bit of a pickle we've got a lot of areas
that are closed off to us but we did
manage to save which is good so long as
we do not die a horrible horrible death
so it should be okay
tanner tanner tanner okay and I know a
lot of you guys wanted me to pick up
this goddamn not you Emily Rose do I
even need that drop in that I can come
back if I need to get it and I don't
think I need this anymore because I've
got a way better one in my pocket right
now
so if I go over here I grab this if you
bring it he will come I want a ring it
bang bong blings wrong
Bing bong bring it on I don't know if
you improve this in any way but it
wasn't very intimidating last time Bing
bong Bing bong bring it on willow bang
on bang Oh Oh bang bong die [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yo man Jesus I was Bing
bong in somebody else and then you came
a skip step in my way fine
all right let's not do this let's turn
this guy off contain that thing down but
that's all about but time to go get
another bring Parker and bring on
another monstrosity when they wants to
play a little nicer for me so what we
got to do is we got to close up the
doors behind us like we were going to do
but then not leave doors open everywhere
for Billy
alright let's drop this let's grab this
and let's see with this thing deers
Bing bong Bing bong Bing bong hang on
anybody here Bing bong Bing bong bong
Bing bong Bing bong whoa stop that hate
that come on
Bing bong Bing bong well I see how this
is okay close that behind me close this
one wait
begone Oh seems like I might be doing
some bad stuff
bing-bong bing-bong what [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you
alright okay alright okay
then remember the last time that I tried
to do this it didn't kill me which was
weird right
God in heaven no that's not what I'm
looking for I'm looking for the SCP note
about this thing because I forget what
it actually does like I honestly have no
idea all I know is that I really like
the pong ping it I'm going to spring
sprung it as much as I can
bang boy long
[Music]
bing-bong bing-bong bing-bong bing-bong
bang okay oh nine six is nearby 173
seems to have [ __ ] off I don't know
what this Bing bong Bell does and I
think I'm gonna be lost about that for a
while so what I got to do is I got to
find a way to go through heavy
containment because if I can find a way
through heavy containment that'll
actually be good for me because I need
to unlock it first but that's the only
way that I can Pro Bing bong are you
part of this are you part of this huh
Bing bong who was that
whoa oh [ __ ] all right
okay well this is good I think the thing
I got there I like it this I didn't even
know this was there all righty then
well I don't know if this helps me if
I'm going to see something in the
darkness that I'm not gonna like oh well
we got we got a cry boy over here
somewhere we got a lot of doors open
over here which I don't like
hey radical Larry shut the [ __ ] up god
dammit god dammit god dammit [ __ ] off so
many open doors not good not good not
good not good
why don't I get lost - [ __ ] I'm over
here maybe I could try to contain him
[ __ ] so he's coming after me into his
own containment area which might means
that I'm able to contain him which I
don't know if I'm gonna want to save
doing that because I bang bong - bling
blong no no we'll see all right come on
I'm out what you got where am I going
you know boy that ain't good that ain't
good how do I do this I forget I got a
torture someone inside of it don't I
isn't that the whole deal he's attracted
to people in pain for some reason
[ __ ] weirdo whoa oh oh oh oh that
ain't good Pataca then I got that a good
g JJ JJ JJ you got a connect power or
something how do you do this again oh
here we go
uh-huh the mountain whoa what the [ __ ]
is it laughing okay I got to turn that
off and then I got to do this I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna save just yet just
in case I do uh not do that
there we go
[Music]
I don't know I can't and is being idea
that I was going to track Larry in there
out the whole complex can't hear that
because that's oh thank you something
oh so he's in there now because now I
got a Reba vent plan and now we've
contained right right right that's how
it works right I think anyway
oh oh whoa whoa I can't thank you god
damn it you ass all right fine you like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you buddy [ __ ] you buddy
[ __ ] you buddy I contained you I ruined
my one chance at that you know what I
might as well go into a shadow dimension
because I'm probably gonna die from the
cowbell I want to make sure and I want a
second crack at that one hello hi hello
no boy here we go
what kind of world a madness of you
entering now a bad one I know that I
know that for a fact the bad one is I
don't know if there's been any changes
to this area am I in the area oh I can't
see [ __ ]
it's still waking up am let me blink
this out of my eyes Hey ah good well
I've got night vision goggles which is
going to help me see which paths are bad
for me good okay this way Oh at that
counter Wumpus that's all wampie whoo
people you make our way out of here in
whatever horrible month
go away okay then
well these all lead to wondrous places
yeesh I guess it looked this way well
join your faint screaming in the
distance I bet I do it'll get here whoo
well that looks bad I'm not gonna go
near that one all right a wing grill it
would be great if I wasn't walking with
my head tilted like this now let's see
if we can go by this thing now can I see
it oh that's what it was doing
oh okay just making a figure eight
pattern like go now and let me wait a
second whoo I just gonna stop here oh
nice okay I think we made it dirty
gumdrops that's why what what what oh
come on alright that's fine that's fine
it's fine okay we're coming back into it
now we're not gonna get the Bell because
I don't want a thing flung bring that on
I want a ping-pong leave that the [ __ ]
alone and then hopefully not die when
scp-173 decides to rear its ugly head
I believe ooh maybe I should go down oh
whoa are you talking about here are you
dying it up huh
wait you hitting me what why why were
you hey [ __ ] you man this elevator for
sharing oh well this ain't good I'm
bleeding profusely because I'm being
slapped to death by an unfriendly ghost
ghost dick sir over here keeps slapping
me out the side the head
[ __ ] this guy this isn't one of those
cool ghosts
you could feel something near you but
you're unable to see it perhaps if time
is now don't know what that means
I keep getting slapped oh I feel
something here weird
I'm gonna go get the night vision
goggles once it kills me and I start
over again I've slowed the game would
that have shown up on my radar like
wooden would that have actually showed
up on my navigator because it would have
like that would have made a lot of sense
right
tiverton SCP that's slapping me in the
darkness but I got to go get the
night-vision goggles first before I do
that and then I should be okay okay okay
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa away okay okay
okay okay okay oh oh that is not okay
oh that is so not okay oh that is a
hundred percent not okay oh my god oh
[ __ ] you dude
oh [ __ ] you what do I do about you [ __ ]
you just wants to return to that
elevator [ __ ] alrighty then you just
keep going you keep going [ __ ] you dude
[ __ ] you dude okay so I'm gonna just
ignore him for now get close to go Arun
behind me and he likes to stab me with
his claw hands oh this is where
nine-tailed Fox comes in and shoots
everybody are you in here here okay so
I'm gonna go down this elevator and I'm
gonna see if I survived
I don't think I'm gonna but I'm gonna
try real hard okay what the [ __ ] just
happened
oh no no no no no none of that none of
that please none of that no none of that
[ __ ] I don't like is that oh I don't
like this one bit
oh boy oh no it's that guy but now it is
home turf pop out of that room I know he
is like gangbusters [ __ ] okay elevator
power feed level for car don't need it
so like a safe monitor here no coursers
and [ __ ] he's out of here on oh boy oh
boy oh hi zombie okay what do I do about
this elevator power feed generator yeah
stay away from me buddy stay away from
me and then you mean you and then you
know you do not oh I'm gonna put on my
gas mask and I'm gonna breathe so easy
around you I want to go in there but I
don't I want to but I really don't okay
all can't see [ __ ] Hubble okay elevator
good good yes yes please play oh [ __ ] me
run run run run run run run oh [ __ ] run
run Oh shitty tix
[ __ ] my dicks [ __ ] me dude [ __ ] that
[ __ ] you dude oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
come on now would be the time thank you
thank you thank you thanks piggy mmm
all right anyway oh man that was a
fruitless adventure [ __ ] me [ __ ] that
[ __ ] me okay I'm gonna go back in here
I'm gonna try this again I guess I can
save though before I do someone do that
try to contain this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
save Heights
so I'm gonna turn on the audio feed to
creamer breaker give him the old one-two
creamer break oh sorry okay I forgot
about this
okay hopefully that works well I don't
know
stop complaining to get contained go to
radical Aries fun house of horrors where
you want to be it's where everybody
wants to be
[Music]
okay all right okay we're yet oh yeah be
well yeah buddy good yes go to do areas
okay serious I'm gonna go for now feed
cancer the audio feed offset I'm just
gonna assume though that he got
contained what the [ __ ] was that you
guys see that
yeah I don't like this at all it'd be
contained though let me go down and
double-check but I think I got him quote
well [ __ ] you walk in it I think I got
him
holy [ __ ] I got him oh my god I got him
good for me okay cool that's great okay
I got him yeah I got him
so that means that he is never gonna be
a problem again
holy [ __ ] I get that okay so imma save
there and then I'm going to end the
episode but I want to do more this
because there's a lot of new stuff in
here that I wanted for a lot of
improvements a lot of changes and again
developers you deserve something for
this got it so good undertow Games
you're just awesome so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
everybody through its developed obtained
so far and thank you to everybody that
supported it I want to do a few more
episodes and let me know where you can
cut in the common core and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]